how do you reward and incentivize a
willingness to be uncomfortable I like
to hire for intelligence and grit and
skill I think leads you down a wrong
path when your job is to invent new
things because there's no historic skill
that you can often hire for yeah that
yields new inventions like if you're
going to create something new you can't
do it with people who know how to do
something and have done it for 30 years
you have to do it with someone who can
look in first principles and deconstruct
a problem and with intense level of
curiosity figure out how to do it better
in a way that no one else has ever
thought about because they don't even
know that they're not following the
rules or following the prescriptive way
that it's been done before the more you
push into uncomfortable the more
creative you could be